via mer tiger the largest cat in the
world and a powerful Chinese symbol is
threatened with extinction but to
researchers at the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies are
turning to high-tech tools to save the
Tigers forested habitat so she know what
you should do before I don't go a leash
so why don't you go fetch o Shanter need
that you go for how women aha central to
all passing generally I didn't teach
only some don't there are many factors
that are of concern that have caused its
present condition and part of it is an
expansion of agriculture into that
region which limited the amount of
habitat for the tiger the another one
was the amount of hunting of the tiger
that was done and another one was the
condition of the forest itself now those
three led the tiger to a quite low level
at present only 800 ameri Tigers remain
in the wild confined to a reserve in
northeastern China and southern Siberia
professor Oliver and Xu Mei Hong have
been studying how different types of
forests can affect the cat survival our
understanding of how forests grow has
changed dramatically in the last hundred
years and more specifically in the last
two or three decades the old theory was
that the natural forest was this stable
low
most forest with trees dying in the
upper canopy and providing room for
other trees to grow up through the
forest beneath own now scientists began
questioning this and now the
predominance of scientific evidence and
the predominance of scientists accept
that forests and much more dynamic than
that everywhere in the world that we
have studied we find that the forest is
constantly subjected to various
disturbances the researchers have
discovered that the density of the
forest may be excluding some of the
Tigers favorite prey thus endangering
its survival no I infer Managua Judy Joo
Shin Jung ko Paul don't break em Japan
bahu Tom Verducci put in tha kal ho na
ho Oh Mia tell Colin bajo oh don't know
who the Leo boj co-ordinator dango hold
on that helper who alternated on the
show on TV as I ya bajo couldn't ground
the jubilation so about the Bahujan
don't be a homo chances German the
Bahujan question test it on the quota
would you that I did it and I shall
behold humble who is a hundred other but
we are concerned that the recovery may
be partly related to the condition of
the forest itself
what happens is that in the last past
century there was very heavy harvest of
that forest timber harvest so now the
forest has grown up so that it's gone
through the open structure and Juma's
research is showing that very much of it
is in that dense structure so now that
the forest is all in that dense
structure it really doesn't leave very
much room for the Amur tigers prey to
survive the Yale researchers are working
on a solution using a computer program
called landscape management system or
LMS they can design the ultimate habitat
incorporating areas for the tiger itself
and its prey oh wow shauna joe dimaggio
dissemination shijou on video from fuda
now ho Colonel condescending t a NGO dou
zai jian de johnson amazing investment
dimensional array show jennifer me know
taeho hi oh taeho de dao jia shi shi jia
toledo taman taman xie peidong mamita
standing by to a pretty high in hotel
Sevilla are you sure she not like Tommy
xie xie mommy to send alerts Oh chica
the holy man for me not shown
joshiya tombe hold additional booty see
aunty Lee Dong Tam NCC Shahenshah ejido
Imperial o cake order howdy-ho darshan
general thalia like to [ __ ] Xu Mei is
mapping a tiger habitat in several ways
she's doing two things the first is
using satellite imagery we've obtained
from various sources around the world
then she will take the data from the
Chinese Forest Service and put it into a
landscape management system so it allows
us not only to develop a plan but we can
also show visualizations of it we can
show maps of it it'll allow us to get a
more complete plan as well as an
understanding of how we can manage the
forest the LMS model shows that allowing
the forest to grow densely and unmanaged
actually works against the health of the
tiger it's somewhat of a race against
time in that the more we insist on these
clothes dense forests and the less that
we allow opening Savannah's in this
mosaic the more we start to diminish the
populations of species that depend on
these openings today with a little help
from its friends the future for the
America is a bit brighter when I say
that I'm optimistic about the future of
the tiger i would say i'm hopeful it's a
question of if we can get the science
right and we can get it enough habitat
i'm hoping that we can come up with
robust mechanisms for maintaining these
species whatcha want the real I see
Rhonda you may
so Jennifer me know and I'll judge
Conklin didn't want I should let see
unique for me Anton Ferdinand tio de
hacerlo por trabajo cuando yo zushi show
confundi yo todo todo companies in TC so
titus ramiz al trabajo sanchita from
jita media noche de gr woman [ __ ] Uncle
Tom RT continuity and Joe Hall altered
out da Jung Sher the function in
waldoboro sure click create widget for
more information about the Yale School
of Forestry and environmental studies
visit environment yale edu
I